who is that mysterious FBI man The
Dashing lead of the night agent has a
face that lots of viewers May recognize
from other TV shows and movies if you're
not sure where he may have seen actor
Gabriel basso before we've got you
covered producer and writer Sean Ryan
knows a thing or two about intense
episodic drama series his shows
including SWAT Timeless and the shield
have all led him to the new Netflix
series The Night agent a 10 chapter
Thrill Ride that dropped on March 23
2023. it's an adaptation of the 2019
best-selling novel of the same name by
author Matthew Kirk like the book The
Show follows a low-level FBI agent
posted in the underbelly of the White
House to man a telephone hotline meant
for American spies in dire need but one
phone call is all it takes to send this
agent into a tangled web of conspiracy
is this a Sidewinder or gazelle what I
don't understand viewers will quickly
find that this particular FBI agent
Peter Sutherland didn't land in the
basement of the White House due to
inexperience before being stationed at
the Spy hotline he discovered a bomb
planted on a passenger train pulling the
emergency brake before the bomb actually
goes off targets him as a suspect which
leads to his miserable position but
agent Sutherland soon finds himself
embroiled in a thrilling plot that only
heat can unravel like Sutherland the
actor who plays him Gabriel basso has
plenty of experience under his belt
basso is a young teen when he started
his career by scoring several minor
roles in TV series including Ghost Town
iCarly and the middle the St Louis
natives breakout role was in director
J.J Abrams Super 8 which follows a group
of young teenagers who use the Super 8
movie camera to film their own zombie
movie in their small Ohio Town while
shooting a nighttime scene for their
homemade flake they witness a train
derailment that sets off a real-life
1980s sci-fi thriller essos Martin Reed
plays the lead in the movie The
teenagers are making but the chaos of
the train derailment separates the group
while also unleashing a dangerous alien
presence Martin who good friends with
one of the amateur filmmakers Joe is
injured by military tanks and is forced
to hide out of sight the character
eventually plays a critical role in the
movie's Climax and the 2011 film helped
Propel basso's career to the next level
I also added a coming-of-age comedy to
his resume with 2013's The Kings of
Summer the movie follows Three teen
friends who decide to spend their summer
vacation building a house in the woods
while disconnecting from the outside
world the trio successfully constructs
the crew dwelling while dealing with all
the emotions and drama that comes with
being a team
ASO plays Patrick protagonist Joe's best
friend he joins the adventure because he
is tired of dealing with his irritating
parents at home as the house is coming
along Joe decides to bring his Crush
Kelly to see it but that backfires as
she develops a crush on Patrick instead
Kelly eventually starts a relationship
with Patrick causing friction between
him and Joe Kings of Summer is an
independent film that not everyone may
have seen but it was honored at a number
of film festivals and has a very
respectable 76 Rotten Tomato score basso
made his way to TB with the Showtime
original series The Big C portraying
Adam Jameson Adam is the son of Laura
Lenny's Kathy who is being diagnosed
with terminal cancer and he attends the
same school where Kathy works as a
teacher with his mother deciding not to
reveal Her diagnosis to him until the
very end of season one he is forced to
deal with the ongoing unexplainable
changes in their relationship
hope you're gonna be okay Adam finally
unleashes his emotions After he finds a
storage unit full of future birthday and
holiday gifts his mother has gotten for
him by the end of the final season Kathy
has her son open all the presents so
they can have the experience together
knowing that his mom will most likely
not make it to a scheduled High School
graduation he accelerates his credits
with online courses to receive his
degree leading to an emotional moment
where Kathy gets to see him in his cap
and gown with his diploma vessel also
co-starred in the 2020 film hillbilly
elegy directed by Ron Howard the movie
was based on the 2016 novel of the same
name by now U.S senator J.D Vance it was
met with mixed reviews despite receiving
nominations for multiple categories at
the Academy Awards Screen Actors Guild
Awards and Golden Globes basil plays JD
a Yale law student forced to return home
to care for his mother who was overdosed
on heroin Vaso puts in an emotional
performance as his character attempts to
hold his family together during such a
trying time his mother Bev played by Amy
Adams continues to relapse while JD does
his best to encourage her his persistent
pays off not only does he support his
mother who we see by the end of the
movie has been sober for six years but
he graduates from Yale and starts his
own family he even moves back home to be
closer to his mom and grandmother
[Music]